[Musique]
monsieur vous avez vu ces rapports homme
que si vous en pensez celui là pourquoi
parce que ça fait trop fait bien annonc
é par guy sont pas viril mais je trouve
qu'ils n'ont pas d'alluré avec leur
drogue
oh moi je trouve que c'est pas bon et ça
me plaît pas maintenant je suis pour la
mad men commence à parler c'est pour moi
un homme s'est fait un nom en tablier
suffit pour l'instant c'est trop curieux
et ce qui est dit comme ça mais vous
rigolez ou quoi
alors ok on en perd la cour un homme ou
une femme et leur âme souhait ce qui
l'attend à l'eau en signant pour les uns
et les autres ont tous sens on n'arrive
pas un homme comme ça parce que j'ai
regardé qu avec capture en délire
mascarade où sa fantastique en avait
tellement menthe ou 7 10 hommes en gris
crois que c'est la première vraie
innovation en matière de mode masculine
[Musique]
l'essayer c'est l'adopter